welcome to metaphysical milkshake I am
your host Reza Aslin and I'm your
secondary host rain Wilson thanks for
tuning in everybody rain this is
somewhat of a sad sad day for us it's
kind of a sad day it's a little bit of a
sad episode a little bit of a sad
episode yeah yeah do you wanna do you
want to tell the listeners what's going
on well folks after nearly 100 episodes
of metaphysical milkshake after we have
tackled some of life's biggest questions
what happens when we die you know how
many universes are there how does the
world come to an end
it's time for us to
hang up our metaphysical hats is that a
thing I mean
I'm not wearing it well we want to hang
up our metaphysical hats for now this
has been a really amazing ride with a
lot of episodes but we might be back we
might put our metaphysical hats back on
again it's just for we're in a kind of
indefinite Hiatus here folks we'd love
to hear from you if you'd like us back
you can write us at metaphysical at
cast.com with this cast of the K hit us
up on the social media or if you don't
want us back you could also please
welcome to metaphysical Milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of Life along
the way presented by cast media and
Seoul pancake
[Music]
no we've uh We've we've created a great
number of incredible uh conversations
and we just need a little break
got books coming out we've got TV shows
TV shows we're working on so we just
needed a little a little rest but I
truly hope that we can revisit the
metaphysical uh milkshakers
um at some point in the next year which
of course begs the question what are we
going to do now what are we going to do
with it for this last uh
this show did you book a guest well I
didn't book a guest because I thought
that you and I I mean the last thing we
want to do the last thing we should do
is any kind of like self-promotion or
anything like that I mean we should just
talk about the episodes our favorite
ones what moved us what ideas
um
one thing I could do we I suppose we
could what's I suppose
what's that pretty purple book this book
that I'm holding up uh to our YouTube
audience oh it did just where did this
come from what the I I did not expect
this uh this happens to be a book called
an American martyr in Persia the Epic
life and tragic death of Howard
basketball and let me see who's the
author oh what would you look at that
it's me
hey wait this wait I got one too this
got sent to me in the mail what the now
that is a coincidence I feel like as two
fairly spiritual people we should see
this as a sign uh from the heavens that
maybe uh we should do a little
self-promotion no no wait wait a second
wait a second just as by way of the
beginning of this discussion who was
Howard Baskerville just in a nutshell
well it's funny you should ask
Howard Baskerville was a 22 year old
Christian Missionary from Nebraska of
all places North Platte Nebraska
who in 1907 it's a long time ago
traveled from Nebraska to
Persia
what we now call Iran in order to teach
English and history and preach the
gospel showed up at a kind of an
auspicious time showed up in the middle
of what history now knows as the Persian
constitutional Revolution the very first
Democratic revolution in the Middle East
and after about a year and a half of you
know putting his head down and trying to
ignore things and teach his classes and
preach the word of God he ultimately
gave up his teaching position gave up
his missionary position gave up his
American citizenship
reconstituted his students into a
militia and fought alongside them in
that Revolution against the tyrannical
Shah and ended up dying a heroic death a
martyr's death he is truly considered a
martyr in Iran an American martyr and
this is the first biography ever written
about him thanks for asking for a couple
of things so this Howard Baskerville he
was really selfless right well
he's filled with that he was filled with
idealism and had a pure heart
he was definitely filled with idealism
so one of the things that I I covered so
he would not be in favor of us having
the conversation about this book right
now is what I'm saying ah right
himself is rolling in his grave that we
are utilizing our last metaphysical
milkshake episode in a long while to
plug your stupid book okay Counterpoint
calculate
you know when I was a kid growing up in
Iran this was many many years ago before
the 1979 Revolution
everybody knew Howard basketball's name
all Iranians knew who hired basketball
was this like heroic American who gave
up everything including his life in
order to fight for Iran's Freedom you
know against the tyrannical Shah his
tomb is still in the city of Tabriz
where where he lived and where he died
people used to come from all over the
country to visit his tomb and and to and
to pay homage to this American Christian
Missionary you know who came to save
souls and instead ended up you know
fighting alongside the people he was
there to to bring Salvation to there's a
a beautiful golden bust of him in the
Constitution Museum
but then after the 1979 Revolution
pretty much all memory of Howard
Baskerville was wiped all Iranians
Collective uh memories like I If you go
to Iran right now and you say Howard no
one knows what you're talking about no
one really knows who Howard Baskerville
is I had actually someone in Iran go to
Tabriz go to the museum
and the docent who was like showing her
around the museum including the
Baskerville stuff had no real idea who
Howard basketball was and like didn't
want to talk about still Howard
Baskerville stuff in the
Museum's still there the bus is still a
painting let me ask you let me ask you a
larger question because we're a
metaphysical show so Paul I'm just gonna
I'm gonna give in to the fact that we're
having a conversation about your second
book
um comes out October 11th available at
all bookstore okay all right wait wait
okay okay so I I know you I've known you
for a long time
let's let's I wanna I wanna start with
the deepest possible questions there's a
lot more details I I want to know about
his history and what he did and what he
didn't do and what was going on and you
know a history of Iran in the 20th
century is not something that most
Americans are very familiar with but why
did you write this book why would you
write a book about an American martyr in
Iran who died at age 22. he died at 24
yeah
um he arrived at 22. because I know you
you're up to something I am you're
always up you're always poking the bee's
nest so what is it about this young
Howard Baskerville well look on the one
hand this is somebody that everyone
should know about I mean it's it's crazy
that this you know incredibly heroic man
is somebody that like 99.9 of Americans
had never heard of before and a Greek
Christian too right so the Christian
side of our nation
Evangelical Christian Protestant
missionary I mean that's who this this
guy was so partly it's just to you know
make sure people uh know this person
this first biography ever written about
him uh partly it's obviously to
challenge you know the the the uh
narrative that we hear so often about
America and Iran right these are two
countries that have really been at odds
for decades now and there's a lot of
conversation about you know Iran calls
America the great Satan and you know
America uh refers to Iran as a terror
State Etc et cetera a lot of anger a lot
of animosity and yet here's this
American who died for Iran uh and so in
a way he can act as a sort of bridge
possibly a a way of of reconciling maybe
at the very least coming to some kind of
mutual understanding between these two
countries but but you got me you got me
there is there is a little alternative
goal that I have here
and you know partly it has to do it's
actually a lot like Zealot like my book
Zealot you know which was also about a
young idealistic religious Firebrand who
you know fought a revolution in the name
of the weak and the dispossessed
marginalized and attacked he was Jesus
I'm not saying basketball is Jesus but
it's a it's a Fame
but for me you know we've if we're going
to go back on these whatever nearly 100
episodes of metaphysical milkshake that
we've had
and we're going to talk about like what
is one of the more common themes that
has come up in these episodes
it's been the whole like faith without
Deeds right
values without action like that that is
something that we have repeatedly talked
about just we have no tolerance for
right people who spout the things that
they believe but don't actually ever put
them into play and what I really really
admire about this kid this kid and
that's what he was
is that he went to Iran because he
believed in Jesus Christ he believed
that Jesus was the Lord and savior he
believed that all people needed to know
Jesus otherwise they would burn in hell
and so and he wanted to convert
muhammadans that's what he that's what
he said yeah I'm going to do the
Muhammad didn't work that's I'm gonna go
and make turn these Muslims into
Christians and he went there and he
tried he tried you know he uh according
to all the documents that we have was
very open about his faith shared it with
everyone shared it with all of his
students and as far as we know he'd
never converted a single person like not
not one like I I've scoured the
historical documents there's like nobody
no I mean he had his best friend was
Persian uh you know he uh one of his
favorite students wrote a nice little
thing about him nobody converted can I
just interject absolutely as a Baha'i
because as a member of the Baha'i faith
we hold a lot of similarities to Islam
you you know in Islam there's this idea
that there are they are people of the
book that Abraham you know Moses some of
the other lesser prophets of the Old
Testament and Jesus were all prophets
from God they were all divinely sent
they're all divinely inspired and so
Muhammad mohammedans Muslims Revere and
love Jesus Christ so but they view that
as just folded naturally into their
religion so there it would just almost
be silly for them to kind of say oh wait
but now I have to reject Muhammad
um in order to really love Jesus Christ
no I can love Muhammad and I can love
Jesus Christ and I can love Moses and
and Abraham and and and and and all of
the great spiritual teachers absolutely
just FYI absolutely well and I would say
one other thing so there is a real
fascinating fundamental difference
between Islam and Christianity and to
put it in academic term terms
Christianity is what we refer to as an
orthodoxic religion it's all about
Doctrine and correct belief and Islam
like Judaism for that matter is what we
refer to as an orthopraxic religion it's
all about the things that you do so to
put it in the simplest terms to be a
Christian means to believe a certain set
of things but to be a Muslim or a Jew
means that you do a certain set of
things right you have to actually act in
a certain way it's the things that you
do that make you a Muslim whereas it's
the things that you believe that make
you a Christian and you could see the
conflict here here's this kid going
around trying to convert these Muslims
to Christianity in the middle of a
revolution in which these people are
fighting for their lives for their
freedoms in which they are being
oppressed and marginalized and and at
the end of this story literally starve
to death and gunned down and get
arrested and right and here's this you
know well-meaning kid being like hey you
know you should know Jesus because he'll
save your soul and they're like my soul
like that's not how this works man
that's not how religion in Iran Works in
general including the Baha'is but it's
certainly not how Islam works and so
what I find most remarkable about
basketball is here is this kid who very
quickly realized
if I'm going to actually
really and truly walk in Jesus's
footsteps
I need to do what Jesus would do right
now in the face of such horror and
suffering and violence so he turned from
an orthodoxic to an orthopractic kind of
a believer in the midst of this
revolution he put his faith into action
that's what he did but isn't there also
an element of the American Revolution
and all this and and how Evangelical
Christianity has been kind of wedded
with the constitution in a way that he
also saw the mirrors of the American
Revolution the parallels he was referred
to as the American Lafayette yeah in
Iran that's right and so isn't there
kind of like yes there's a shift in like
what would Jesus do like the bumper
sticker what would Jesus do well Jesus
would try and fight in the cause of John
I don't know if Jesus would fight anyone
but he would certainly protest and be a
part of the cause of justice but also
that just like people like gotta have my
Bible and my Constitution one in each
hand he kind of wanted to to be a great
American revolutionary in Iran well one
of the more fascinating things about
basketball that I uncovered was that he
went to Princeton at a time in which uh
Woodrow Wilson was the president of the
school and he arrived in Princeton a few
years after uh Wilson had enacted what
we nowadays all commonly referred to as
the electives system you can thank
Woodrow Wilson for your college
electives that was basically his
Innovation and so although he went to
Princeton to study Christian Ministry
that's what he was there for it was all
about reading the Bible uh you know
scriptural exegesis like it was Bible
Bible Bible Bible Bible his junior year
he had to take these electives and what
does he do he takes two electives with
Woodrow Wilson himself one in
constitutionalism and one in
jurisprudence and look there's a lot to
hate about Woodrow Wilson starting with
the fact that he was isn't despicable
unrepentant racist I mean like this man
I mean I could I could kill you a lot of
stories about how racist Woodrow Wilson
was but let's just start with the fact
that when he was president of the United
States he actually premiered Birth of a
Nation at the White House okay yeah
that's didn't he also fire uh forbid all
African Americans from working in
government jobs federal jobs yeah yeah
he basically rid the DC bureaucracy of
all black people absolutely I mean but
despicable in a million ways but this is
so we're doing a little sidebar here we
want to get back to Baskerville in
Woodrow Wilson's classes
unconstitutionalism at Princeton in his
electives that's all great but this
almost could be its own episode of uh
metaphysical milkshake I'm not sure that
we're the podcast to cover it but I'm
I'm just reading about you know so much
uh hullabaloo about removing Wilson's
name from Princeton from the library etc
etc
and because he was such a racist
and at the same time Wilson created the
League of Nations dude I know and he
also believed in in god-given right of
democracy that democracy was a god-given
human right that people should have a
voice and a voice for change in their
own country he helped win the first
World War I mean yeah yeah this guy like
I mean
National conversation like as we go back
into the history of our founding fathers
we're going to find more and more racism
and sexism even in San Francisco they
tried to tear down a statue of Abraham
Lincoln because Lincoln was a bastard to
the Native Americans and sentenced a
bunch of them to death for fighting in
the in quote unquote Indian Wars they're
just trying to save their lands and
their families and so Lincoln was racist
against the natives and so every and
everyone pre let's say 1980 is is is
going to be is going to inherit a
certain measure of racism and sexism and
classism and and what have you this
needs to be a national conversation like
do we ban them and ban their names I
mean it's easy for me to say as a white
guy like if I was a black kid at
Princeton I don't want the name of
someone who sure actively hated black
people above a building but at the same
time you have to acknowledge a little
bit of the good I mean the bad Wilson's
family were slave owners he was a
fervent supporter of the Confederate
cause long after the Civil War was over
like it was already done and he was
still alive the Confederacy should have
won which is crazy considering that he
became president uh he was an avid
supporter of the KKK like absolutely
thought that they were like a jewel of
Southern Pride you know by the time he
was president of Princeton all the other
Ivy League schools had started letting
black students in but Wilson was like
nope not gonna do it not a friend
Princeton and then on the flip side of
that this is a man who
you know is one of the fathers of
international law created the the
precursor to the United Nations
um had this incredibly sophisticated
Global understanding and as you rightly
say believed that freedom and democracy
were not American ideals they were
divine mandates that they that it was
sort of God's Commandment that all
people everywhere had a say in the
governments that ruled over them in the
decisions that govern their lives and he
preached this to generations of
Princeton kids and then ultimately of
course it became sort of the foundation
of his presidency and Baskerville at
what like 20 years old was one of those
kids just listening to these great
orations from soon to be president of
the United States Woodrow Wilson about
how it is the responsibility of all
Americans to make sure that everybody in
the world is free because if everybody
in the world is free then is not free
then no one is free and this gets into
them right so it just starts burning
this hole into his chest where he's like
okay my dad is a country preacher my
grandfather is a country preacher I came
to Princeton in order to become a
country preacher but I'm not going to do
that anymore I'm gonna I'm gonna go out
into the world and yes I'm gonna go out
of the world and convert the masses
that's what I'm you know I'm gonna be a
missionary but for him the sort of the
Divine message that he had and his
fervent belief in the political rights
of of people were absolutely enmeshed
there were one in the same as far as he
was concerned amazing so this 22 year
old kid goes to teach at a an American
School in Tehran
yeah it's a North Northwest uh of the
country to paint a picture if you will I
find this fascinating as as a Baha'i
who's in the roots of our faith is in
Persia in Iran mostly in the 19th
century but
um I find it really fascinating uh
there's an incredible
uh contradictory uh dichotomous history
of the Shahs in Iran because to be a
Shaw's to be a king right you're just a
Divine but you're it's like Louis XIV
it's a divinely appointed King that that
that rules unquestioningly that is and
oddly enough what and maybe you can help
explain this to me the Shaws throughout
history were always battling with the
Muslim clergy yeah even though the Shahs
were
believed to be by everyone divinely
appointed and kind of pillars of Islam
there were Islamic divinely appointed
Kings and yet they were always in these
battles power battles and power grabs
with the various kind of clergy members
who who hated and resented the Shahs and
in part of the Iranian Revolution in
1979 was the kind of bringing down of
the shaw you know which and it but the
roots of that were 200 years old with a
distrust of of the shaw but Shaws were
worshiped worshiped uh in the 19th
century and early 20th century in Iran
can you tell us a little bit more about
that milieu that Baskerville found
himself yeah this has been a fraught
relationship for centuries as you say
you're right actually what's really
fascinating is that the the origins of
this conflict between the clergy and the
Shah starts with this story with the
Persian constitutional Revolution that
that Howard basketball thought in
because before then for a while the
clergy just sort of stayed out of
politics altogether you know they the
sheism is a weird religion it's
Messianic and so they believe that only
the Messiah can be the true leader and
so all leaders on Earth are just either
temporary temporary leaders or not real
leaders and so it doesn't matter
democracy uh communism uh you know
fascism
a king like what who cares because
eventually the world will end the
Messiah will come he'll create the
perfect order and he's the only person
who has the right to actually rule
Society
then you know for a little while
they you had a lot of uh conflicts as
you say at the end of the of the 19th
century beginning of the 20th century
where certain clergy especially sort of
Firebrand preachers were causing some
trouble you know really questioning the
actions of the Shahs and what the Shahs
did was brilliant is they just bought
them all they just brought the clergy
into the court and gave them all you
know uh money and allowances and and
great positions essentially shut them up
land gave them wealth uh bought bought
their loyalty do you know at that time
at the turn of the century how many
thousands of people were in this kind of
like governmental court system that had
been created by the Shaws I mean it's
thousands and thousands of people that
were on they're on the Dole given land
given titles and positions kind of
pitted one against another she had this
whole ruling class that was bought off
in corruption in fact this is this is
how this shows it was so ridiculous just
as like you know these sycophants and
bootlickers you know thousands and
thousands of people who are being paid
off by the court it was so ridiculous
that during this time
if you want it to be the governor of a
province let's say you know in Tabriz
um the way that you would become
governor is you would pay the Shah to
become governor you basically you know
people would bid
so in the highest bidder would become
the governor and then the way that the
governor would make up all the money
that he spent in order to become the
governor was to like randomly tax the
people that he was uh you know supposed
to govern and then basically pocket most
of that money and send you know the
remainder off to Tehran and the
government so it was just corruption
from the top to the bottom
and then
at the start of the 20th century a group
of young you know sort of Western
educated fire brand revolutionaries and
business interests you know the
merchants the bizarry people a lot of
power and then this kind of new
generation of clergy uh this clergy who
were dedicated to social justice and
economic Justice and uh Iranian
nationalism banded together and created
this revolution that ended up creating a
a constitution a parliament and then
ultimately that's the revolution that
that Howard Baskerville joined but what
was really fascinating is that that
group The Young revolutionary sort of
Western educated intellectuals the
merchant class and the clergy that
Coalition is the same Coalition that in
1979 brought down the last show it's
just unfortunately uh in the
post-revolutionary chaos of those three
groups only one of them controlled the
streets
and that was the clergy and so once the
shot was gone uh that's when the
Ayatollah Khomeini basically used the
chaos that ensued in order to take power
for himself
now Iran has a long history of kind of
blaming imperialist powers in kind of
manipulating the puppet strings of the
Shah or whomever is in power
um that started with the Russians and
the British the US now it's kind of
Israel
um but they were but in a lot of ways
they were right right because
um the British controlled the oil the
Russians controlled the what was the
tobacco I don't I don't remember exactly
but yeah can you tell us a little bit
about these three the three big powers
and what they were doing in Iran uh
around turn of the century and through
the first half of the century it's that
old adage just because you're paranoid
doesn't mean you know people aren't out
to get you right right and yeah it's
true that Iranians you know love to
blame westerners for all of their ills
certainly the Iranian government does
but it's also true that Iran has had
three Democratic Revolutions in the 20th
century the Constitutional revolution of
1905 the national revolution of 1953 and
then the revolution of 1979 and in all
three cases it was essentially the the
uh involvement of Outsiders Russia and
Britain in 1905 uh the United States and
Britain in 1953 and then mostly the
United States in 1979 that came in and
essentially put an end to any hope that
these revolutions would actually result
in a peaceful Democratic constitutional
state and so you know Iran Iranians have
a point Iranians you know talk about uh
you know Israel is behind everything you
know every every problem that we have in
Iran is Israel's fault and that's
obviously ridiculous that said Israelis
are openly assassinating people on the
streets of Tehran you know so you know
you see that and you're like well then
maybe it is their fault that you know
the economy sucks maybe it is their
fault that you know everything's [ __ ]
when was the president of Iran
overthrown because he wanted to
privatize Iranian oil interests and take
those away from the prediction 53 the
prime minister of Iran that's exactly
right yeah the Prime Minister there was
a revolution in 53 we kicked the Shah
out again uh we had a democratically
elected prime minister the first thing
that he did was nationalize the oil
because at that point you know all the
oil was going off to the to uh the
British Empire and uh as a result the
United States the CIA came in and within
a couple of months and a suitcase with
just a hundred thousand dollars they
managed to remove the government remove
mosadek who was the Prime Minister from
power and then literally just like pick
up the Shah and put him right back on
the throne again
right you know so so that happens a few
times you start to you start to think
well maybe it's maybe I'm not paranoid
maybe people are right
so let's go back to Baskerville here
here's this kid he's into Breeze he's
teaching there's revolutionaries all
over the place what happens what are
some bullet points we don't want to give
away the entire book but what are some
bullet points of what happens to him
that leads to his eventual martyrdom
well it's funny because he did not want
to go to Iran at all he had been you
know he was he desperately begged to go
to either China or Japan because he was
hearing all these like missionary
reports right that coming from China and
Japan about how wonderful everything was
China oh people are converting on mass
and Japan is so beautiful and then you
would read these missionary reports from
Iran and they were horrifying they're
like this is the worst place on Earth
these people are the worst every sin
imaginable is present amongst them you
know they are inveterate Liars
muhammadinism is a is a wall that cannot
be broken so the last place he wants to
go to is Iran and of course that's where
he gets assigned so you know he goes
That's what you you know Jesus wants you
in Iran that's where you go and he goes
there and you know really expecting the
worst and almost immediately falls in
love falls in love with the country
becomes deeply close friends with this
amazing character named Hassan Sharif
Sade who basically is like you know he's
one of the great orators of
um the Revolution and they both are
teaching at the same school he falls in
love like literally falls in love with
the daughter of the Headmaster uh of
this of the school
um you know he Gorges himself on Persian
food because like you know he's never
had anything this guy's been eating like
food from Nebraska and he shows up and
he's like what the [ __ ] this is the best
food I've ever had in my life yeah
um
yeah exactly he's got that tadig and and
then on top of all of that
here he is living through like literally
in front of him something that he had
only read about in history books
something that he only talked about in
Woodrow Wilson's classes he's literally
watching a democracy arise in front of
his eyes you know a constitution is
written and and uh and uh passed a
parliament is is created and there are
free and fair elections there are these
like amazing conversations being had in
coffee shops about like what kind of
country are we going to be are we going
to be you know a confederation or a
republic uh you know there are these
conversations about how to how to
properly spend tax revenue it's like he
is living inside of a history book you
know it needs to be said too that this
is not just a revolution this is like
the first revolution in the Muslim world
and the first place in the Muslim world
where this this idea was talk about
revolutionary the idea that people have
rights that peasants that workers that
business owners have rights they should
be heard that their voices should be
heard you know in the halls of
government it's crazy is like
mind-blowing because we're still Louis
14th exactly uh kind of mentality around
the Sun King Shaw being supported by all
these uh boot licker uh clergy yeah
right I mean it's insane the the
Constitution literally says that the
Shah has his position by the will of the
people and the will of the people can
remove him from that position this was
insane talk like that's that's crazy
talk what are you talking about the Shah
was put on his throne cause God put him
on that throne and only God can remove
him from the throne so the very idea
that that's something that people have
the power to do you know was unheard of
at the time people talk a lot about the
Young Turk Revolution but the Young Turk
Revolution was influenced by the Persian
Revolution it was the Persian Revolution
that then you know started getting all
this attention in uh in turkey or in the
Ottoman Empire I should say and all
these young Turks were like hey we want
that too
you know and it was just I it was an
unbelievable moment
um of of Hope and inspiration and and
here's this 22 year old kid who just
finished hearing for an entire year
Woodrow Wilson saying
God's will is for all people everywhere
to be free democracy is a gift from the
heavens and it will eventually uh spread
throughout the entire world and and now
he's like dropped in the middle of
exactly what Woodrow Wilson was talking
about it's happening in front of him and
yet
he is constantly being told by the
church mind your own damn business it is
not your business it's not your problem
by the way at the time the state
department under President Taft was like
oh this is nonsense there's no such
thing as democracy in a Muslim world
that's that doesn't work like that's not
a real thing so absolutely we cannot
support this this Revolution and
absolutely no American you know can
support this revolution so he's got both
the U.S government and his church
telling him none of your business look
the other way and for a year and a half
he does that I mean it's hard but he
does it
until he just can't anymore
and what does he do does he pick up guns
what is he does he help organize what
what is the what's the juice of what he
was actually rolling up his sleeves and
doing there so to back up a little bit
the Constitution is signed by uh
muzafara din Shah a parliament is opened
there's elections Iran is now a
constitutional monarchy the first
constitutional monarchy in the history
of the Middle East it's a it's an
amazing moment and then that Shah dies
and his son becomes the next shot this
35 year old kid named Muhammad Ali
becomes a next Shaw and not that
Muhammad Ali and he
is very unhappy with his father and what
his father had done and he's like this
is nonsense the Constitution is [ __ ]
Parliament I mean this this whole thing
is ridiculous and so with the help of
his Russian backers he tears up the
Constitution he rolls cannons to the
Parliament building and he blows it up
with the parliamentarian still inside
and then and then he declares war on the
revolution manages to recapture the
entire country of Iran every city every
Province every town except Tabriz the
one town that Baskerville uh lives in
becomes essentially the last Bastion of
the Revolution and by 1909
the Shah after trying repeatedly to take
Tabriz by force and failing uh gives up
and says you know what all right if I
can't defeat you I'm just gonna starve
you to death and he besieges the entire
city cuts off all food all water and the
population
in this very gruesome gruesome moment in
Iranian history dies slowly dies uh
women children men corpses on the street
just it is horrific and once again the
church the Presbyterian Church that sent
Baskerville there is saying this is
terrible it's an awful situation our
hearts are breaking but it's none of
your business
it's none of your business you're here
to save Souls not lives
okay so if you want to do good go and
preach the gospel that's how you can do
good and he just can't do it anymore and
so there's this very you know dramatic
moment where he stands in front of his
students
you know in the morning he's there he's
supposed to teach the class and he just
says he literally says I can't do this
anymore I cannot continue to teach you
while on the other side of this wall on
the other side of this window there are
women and children dying on the streets
I can't do that this anymore and so he
says I can't I'm gonna give up my
teaching position and I'm gonna actually
go pick up a rifle and Join the
Revolution and here's the crazy [ __ ]
this is this this is the stuff that like
you see it like in Hollywood movies and
you're like come on come on
he gives this speech to his students and
the students join him
the students stand up they walk out of
school with him and they also Join the
Revolution so he's like this kind of
demented Pied Piper like taking his kids
out of this this you know school that
he's supposed to be teaching and instead
he reformulates his students into this
militia they call themselves the army of
Salvation they pick up guns and they
fight against the Shah's troops and
ultimately
in April of 1909 this group Baskerville
this like 24 year old Christian
Missionary who's like had no military uh
you know uh training whatsoever he
literally like learned everything he
knows about the military because he
borrowed some encyclopedia britannicas
and and his band of teenagers decide
that they're gonna break the siege that
you know there's no more food in the
city there's nothing more to do
someone's gotta break through the siege
go and get food so he and his students
on the morning of April 20th uh
volunteer for that job and it's in the
process of trying to break the siege
that he gets shot in the heart and dies
amazing and It ultimately does become
successful though well so this is the
crazy thing is that the backlash from
The Siege and from baskerville's Death I
mean thousands of people came to his
funeral uh in Tabriz and the in the
international attention the this whole
debacle is starting to get starts to
become too much and so the Russians and
the British who were really the the only
people who could control the Shah
basically give him an ultimatum either
declare a ceasefire so that we could
bring food uh and humanitarian
assistance into Tabriz or we're going to
invade
we're literally going to invade your
country and remove you from power so
which one do you want
and which is ironic because these are
the two powers that were basically like
spurring him on you know to do exactly
what he was doing but you know
International embarrassment was just too
much so the Shah has no choice but to
declare a ceasefire and the day after
baskerville's death The Siege is lifted
food is brought into Tabriz but then the
revolutionaries use the ceasefire to
reconstitute regroup March onto Tehran
where they forced the Shah off the
throne send him off into Exile replace
him with his like 12 year old son and
then re-write the Constitution rebuild
the parliament have brand new elections
and the very very first act the first
legislative act of the new Parliament is
to declare Howard Baskerville a hero and
a martyr of of the Revolution you know
it's crazy like that was okay you know
100 and something years ago
you think back now today you know
2022 is that where we're in 20 20. yep
yep to think that like there's a there's
a Christian American Christian
Evangelical missionary in Iran whose
tomb is a pilgrimage site right who's
bust is in a museum displayed in a
museum who until the 79 revolution had
elementary schools named after him right
and who was considered this like hero in
Iran it would be crazy it'd be crazy to
think that about someone like that and
yet that's who it was and so you know
going back to what you were saying
before that's my goal as to make sure
that both Iranians and Americans
remember this kid because he's pretty
much been lost to history
incredible story absolutely astonishing
story I remember you told me years ago
about this guy and how you wanted to
write a book about him and how this
should be a movie
Timothy chalamet but going back to the
Big Ideas here behind this book I love
the idea of
a martyr because in the Baha'i faith
Martyrs hold a big place because tens of
thousands of Baha'is early Baha'is and
Bobby's which proceeded Baha'is gave
their lives for for their faith and
instead of recanting their faith they
were tortured shot out of cannons said
candles stuck into their bodies and they
were burned in the streets Boston Auto
you name it the the idea of martyrdom is
kind of lost in the modern world but
what a perfect example of a martyr this
is guys like let's do this organizes a
militia they March he you know he gets
shot unfortunately but his dying hits
the newspapers all of a sudden the
English and Russians are like oh my God
changes everything he gave his life uh
to Alleve the suffering of The Starving
of Tabriz and to bring a constitution to
the poor people of Iran but this is is
so tell us your feelings about what
martyrdom is and what it means and why
that that that word is so powerful in
this in this book by the way I'm really
glad that you brought up the Baha'is
because they they were pivotal in the
Persian constitutional Revolution and
the bub was actually executed in Tabriz
you know I mean that that was the sight
of his uh execution and and that will
tell you a lot about how Iran works
because it was truly the execution of
the Bob that allowed
for the flowering of bahaism in so many
ways the fact that this guy who had
these incredible ideas he had amazing
spiritual ideas but he had you know
these amazing ideas about the freedom of
the press which is something that Bob
talked about equality of women and men
equality of women yeah yeah which like
no one no one was talking about the
equality of women you know abolitional
clergy not needing clergy
actually science and religion being in
harmony that's right no this is
revolutionary Concepts in the 1840s and
and by the way the first person in Iran
to come up with the concept of a house
of justice which is what the parliament
was he was the first to say we need we
need a place where citizens can go to
where the law is written down and you
could actually have you know access to a
process whereby you know you can be
judged fairly by the law people were
like judged fairly by the law the laws
whatever the Shah says the law is and
this is a man who was willing to die for
those ideas at a time
in which those ideas and his followers
were not that huge the word in which you
know he didn't he he couldn't look ahead
and know that like this was going to
flower into one of the most beautiful
Global religions you know in the world
but he was willing to die for it and
fundamentally I think that's the
question that really animated me about
this book and it's the question at the
heart of martyrdom which is what are you
willing to die for like it's a crazy
idea right and theoretically we could
come up with a million uh you know
answers to that question right from the
comfort of our living rooms I can tell
you a whole host of things that I would
be willing to die for
but then put me in that position
and and then ask me again like what are
you willing to Die For in sheism and in
Christianity martyrdom is very huge the
idea that Jesus sacrificed himself the
in Islam you know the idea that like the
Imam Hussein you know was able to
sacrifice himself martyrdom the idea
that you would lay down your life for a
just cause is in many ways the very core
of Islam and certainly the core of Shia
Islam which is what most uh Iranians are
and for Baskerville
to come into this situation as an
outsider and to say
I have these set of beliefs both
political and religious political in the
sense that all people deserve to be free
religious in the sense that human
dignity human lives matter and they they
need to be protected and for him to say
I'm willing to die for that because you
know I made it sound very heroic he and
his band of students you know we're
going to break through the siege I mean
it was ridiculous it was a suicide
mission it was him and 11 students it
was a dumb
dumb idea but it was born out of
desperation people are dying I have to
do something and so you can say with a
very clear conscience that he went into
that action knowing that very likely he
was not coming back from it
and
that is the thing that made him the hero
in Iran
it's not about what you do or what you
say or even who you are and certainly
not what you believe
it's about what are you willing to die
for
and part of the reason why I think he
has become such a hero is that that
question has always been very important
in Iran whether you're a Iranian
Christian or an Iranian Jew or an
Iranian Baha'i or an Iranian Muslim
there's the Persian culture is all about
this notion of sacrifice what are you
willing to die for that's that's the
most important question
um and will you actually do it will you
put yourself out there
and so to me that's the core of what
martyrdom is right this idea that I have
a set of beliefs a set of values
and
I am going to put those values into
action but I am also going to willingly
if necessary die for those values it's
just we don't really see that that much
anymore you know what I'm saying it's
just not a not a thing Peter singer who
we had on the show
uh gave a very famous Ted Talk
um we might have referenced it in our
conversation with him I can't remember
if it made the edit
um where he showed footage in China of a
girl who had been hit by a car laying in
the street and people were driving past
the dead body for like 20 minutes or
half an hour before someone like stopped
and said hey we need an ambulance and
what's going on here people just ignored
the body right and
then he drew the parallel to like well
wait a second we're doing this every day
we know that people are we know that in
Pakistan right there's thousands of
people starving right now right now from
the floods like we know in the Sudan and
in Ethiopia there's war in Sri Lanka
that people are dying and starving and
yes and people are outraged that people
were driving by this dead body but
aren't we driving by dead bodies every
single day so when you think about
martyrdom like most people would say
like well I would die for my family I
would die for my wife I would die for my
child if someone was threatening them I
would throw my life and I'd okay fair
enough that's that's great that's great
and then it's like well maybe I would
die from my neighbor if I saw someone in
my neighbors or extended family like
this but but but then how wide do we
make that Circle do you know what I mean
how big do it because this is what he
did essentially was
his Circle went from uh his family to
people in Nebraska and South Dakota then
his Circle went to Evangelical
Christians or Princeton grads and all of
a sudden his Circle went to humanity
Muslim women and children of Tabriz are
then my family I'm willing to die for
for them so in a way my point is like
how do we
and answer this question I'll ask you
this question how do we expand that
Circle of what we are willing to
sacrifice our lives for
yeah I think
fundamentally that is the question of
the book it's like literally a question
that I ask you know at the end of it
Baskerville died for strangers
you know these were not his people as
you say like it wasn't they didn't they
weren't Americans they weren't
Christians you know they they were
people that he didn't know you know but
they were suffering and he felt like he
needed to and you're right
as Peter Singer reminded us
yeah people are suffering right now
everywhere and you can do something
about it so why aren't you
and I guess at a time in which you know
we've become
less and less globally aware I think
that's probably true right now we're
becoming more insulated less concerned
about what's happening around the world
there are thousands of people who are
dying in in Pakistan because of you know
uh the the flooding there are millions
of people all over the world whose lives
are at at risk because of climate change
uh or because of abject poverty or
hunger
there are people around the world
who are in need of someone to help them
and we I think have become less and less
interested in those people not more
even this idea that basketball went to
some foreign Strange Land 10 000 miles
away it took them two and a half months
to get there because he thought that
they were deserving a freedom and
democracy like we're not even all that
into democracy here in America anymore
right that's like half of us are like
here's here's what I love no one has to
ever lose an election again yes exactly
we never lose elections no one ever will
lose an election I I tweeted that it's
like a participation trophy no one loses
anyone who lose a quote unquote loses an
election had it stolen and it was right
that's right so no one ever everyone's a
winner everyone's a winner
that's how we think here let alone the
idea of like promoting democracy in
another country are you nuts like that's
not we could barely promote that here
and so in some ways you look at
basketball's actions and and he comes
off as maybe a little naive a little
foolish you know uh it's he's easy to
he's easy to dismiss and make fun of
there's no question about it you know
this white Christian privileged kid who
went to some dark and foreign land in
order to you know bring Salvation uh and
then have this Awakening and really kind
of ended up being saved himself in in a
lot of ways uh because of that Awakening
and these actions
so I really want this book to be a
challenge
to the people who read it I want that
and that's when I was getting that's
what I was getting at at the very
beginning and I know that you don't
write anything unless you are poking The
Beehive unless you are issuing a
challenge to but it's a challenge both
for Christian Americans and it is to
challenge for Muslim Iranians at the
same time it's
a challenge for everyone it's a
challenge for Christians especially in
America
who have gotten to this place where
Christianity means nothing more than you
know uh political power and you know uh
forcing Christian ideas and values uh
upon the the United States I mean
Christians in the Trump years have
gotten a very bad rap and deservedly so
and here's a Christian who says no being
a Christian doesn't mean you know
forcing this or that on someone being a
Christian means acting like Jesus and
dying for strangers that's what being a
Christian means but isn't this a little
bit scary isn't this a little bit scary
that a Christian in in Maga America
could read this and go I am going to die
for Trump I am going to die for those
evil liberals that are tearing our
democracy apart and because a lot of
them are willing to die they're willing
to sacrifice their lives to protect
America from Liberal scum that they
believe by you know uh I think about 60
percent uh are evil for our country
possibly I think a lot of them are
willing to kill for it uh far far fewer
are willing to die for it
but nevertheless it comes back to that
question what are you willing to die for
and by the way this is an American too
this I mean he gave up his citizenship
at the end of his life because he had to
I mean he was literally being threatened
with treason he was told treason you
will be arrested for treason if you
fight in this war and he was like okay
well then I'm guess I'm not American
anymore and he handed his passport in
but unquestionably he was doing this as
an American he believed that this is
what an American would do that like the
idea that democracy is something just
for America is [ __ ] offensive like of
course it's not and so this is me acting
like a Christian this is me acting like
an American and so I think you know it's
something for a lot of us Americans
right now to start thinking about too
what do we owe other people in the world
what do we owe their freedom I want to
say something on that on this word
martyr because I think there's an idea
like we don't martyrdom doesn't
necessarily mean giving your life and
and being shot to death that martyrdom
can mean giving up your comfort your
freedom your status your time to help
others there's a there is a martyrdom a
healthy martyrdom in in service to
others
um so we don't have to think of
martyrdom as like absolutely what am I
am I going to be bionetted or garotted
or brought up in front of a firing squad
but actually it's like working in
selfless service is a kind of that's
right A different kind of martyrdom
that's right it was any kind of like
voluntary suffering it could be economic
suffering it could just be comfort you
know a lot it's about putting other
people first I think that's what that's
what you know a a true martyr is and and
I think that this is somebody who
can be celebrated but also at this time
right now in America and in Iran
certainly you know the the the the sort
of very easy
um way that Iranians uh especially the
government has of just simply demonizing
Americans and Christians for that matter
uh and yet having to come to terms with
this American Christian who was a hero
and by the way this book is being
translated into Persian it'll be uh as a
PDF for free for anyone in Iran to
download uh for free because I want to
make sure that's fantastic same way that
Americans are yeah yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna send it out to all the Persian
Baha'i friends too yeah and this will be
you could probably be arrested in Iran
like a year from now for owning this
book no it's possible it's funny uh I
had like to have this film crew in Iran
doing some filming for me in the and you
know they originally got a permit very
very easy easily to do this because they
said yeah we're doing a little you know
video thing on Persian constitutional
Revolution and and Howard basketball's
role in it and the government was like
fine that sounds great then they started
filming and asking questions and the
more they started asking about
Baskerville in particular this American
Christian Missionary people started to
tense up a little bit and on the third
day they got their permit revoked just
surprised your permit is revoked because
I guess they were just talking too much
about America and again I think that's
what I that's what I want to change I
want to make sure that both Americans
and Iranians remember this name Howard
Baskerville and that that name is a
symbol of everything that these two
cultures these two peoples actually hold
in common with each other it can be a
bridge uh between these two great
cultures and I'm I'm reminded of people
reference it all the time but um the
Anthony Bourdain episode in Iran where
he uh travels around and eats food and
there's some American journalists there
which are subsequently arrested right
after shooting the episode with him yeah
Jason but just shows the incredible
Humanity of Iran people are just so
loving and warm and hospitable and funny
and Goofy and
um it's a it's a really glorious culture
with uh the most amazing food you've
never had
um well I wish you the very best with
this book Reza but um and now he's gonna
segue into something like so what do you
think what would you die for listeners
metaphysical listeners and we would love
to hear from you we'd like to make this
is our our last gasp at least for a
while we would love to hear from you on
our social media at metaphysical
milkshake on Instagram you can write us
at metaphysical at
castmedia.com if you can find us on our
socials rain Wilson at Reza Aslin are we
going to give some of these away we are
we are how's that going to work how's
that going to work it's pretty simple
first five people to write a review of
metaphysical milkshake on Apple podcast
all you got to do is email a screenshot
of the review to metaphysical at
castmedia.com and we'll send you a copy
of the book but
if you're not one of those five people
listen you can still get the book it
just costs a little bit of money that's
all you know how much are we talking
about here how much is this bad boy
think about the hard cover is like 30
bucks but I think the uh Kindle cover or
the other are you reading it or did you
read it on the audible yeah yeah you
could uh get the audible and hear me you
should have me read it read it to you in
a very dramatic
but you know it's hard like I was
looking at I was looking at the um one
can forgive Howard Baskerville for being
lost in such thoughts the past six
months have been a whirlwind of highs
and lows the fall felt like a dream the
thing is I can't afford rain Wilson
that's my problem you cannot I was just
gonna say that uh
Just One Last appeal here is that I was
looking at the non-fiction bestseller
list
and it's all Trump it's either books
about Trump it's either Trump adjacent
books yeah it's or like books that are
like you know not about Trump but sort
of about Trump like a biography of
Lincoln and or you know or like how you
can anti-trump yeah exactly you know and
uh so you know it's hard it's hard when
you've got a book like this to to get a
lot of attention so thank you when does
it come out what's the first week that
it comes out October it comes out
October 11th wow so yeah so hitting the
bestseller list would be helpful and you
can help metaphysical milkshakers please
uh this episode drops on October 11th so
when you hear this these especially
these several days after this podcast
drops the 11th through the 18th or so
like get out there buy several of these
this is a great stocking stuffer this is
the week to buy it help Reza get his
book up on that bestseller list thank
you everyone Reza I don't want to say
like goodbye but um I'm first of all I'm
really congratulations on the book and
I'm really glad that we got to have this
conversation as the as the temporary I
hope sign off of this first long 70 plus
episode chapter of metaphysical
milkshake but uh what an honor and a
thrill to be having these conversations
with you over the last several years I
mean it's it's enriched my life so much
I've learned so much I've thought so
much we've we've got to speak to some
absolutely incredible yeah incredible
human beings and I want to thank
everyone who's been listening and we've
gained a really kind of loyal uh
wonderful audience and just thank you so
much for supporting kind of kind of
uplifting important elevated
conversations about big ideas thank you
for being a part of this we couldn't
have done it without you hopefully we
get to keep going yeah this has been a
truly fantastic experience
um and you know I mean we were friends
before but I feel like we've gotten very
close in these conversations and indeed
and it's been it's just been wonderful
and thank you milkshakers
for for being on this I guess now
three-year Journey with us and uh
you know we love you we love these ideas
and uh and hopefully we'll be back
I hope so too uh milkshakers you guys
are the best we love you so much
congrats on the book pick it up an
American martyr in Persia
Blah Blah Blah Blah by Reza Aslan picked
that up late September early October
thanks for listening hopefully we see
you again tell all your friends to
listen to our 70 to 80 plus episodes
um we would love to have that these
ideas shared by everyone thank you so
much
signing off
[Music]
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rain Wilson Reza Aslan and
Colin Thompson it is produced by Safa
samasade yazd Harris Lane Nick dimaria
Hashem South and DJ lubel cast media is
the production and distribution partner
original music by Jeff Tang
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Timothy chalamet people don't know this
big fan of the metaphysical milkshake
yeah loves the milkshake so typical
milkshaker Timothy if you happen to be
listening
uh you know I think you'd make a great
basketball
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
YouTube channel thank you